مساء الخير،
والمعذرة عن التأخير في إعداد الحلقة وتقديمها،
لقد أُصبت بهذا الفيروس اللعين،
ممّا استوجب قليلا من الراحة،
أتمنى لكم ولكل احبّتكم السلامة والعافية.
نعود إلي الشيخ الأكبر محيي الدين بن عربي،
الذي كان أثره خير أنيس لي في الأيام الفارطة.
في الأربعين من عمره،
وبعد سنوات من الترحال في الأندلس والمغرب الإسلامي،
نزل محيي الدين بن عربي بمكة.
وهناك،
التقى بعالم الحديث الشيخ زاهر الدين ابن رستم الكيلاني،
وسمع منه كتاب سنن الترمذي.
كان لهذا الشيخ بنت تسمى بـ “النظام"،
وتكنّى بقرّة العين،
التقى بها محيي الدين بن عربي صدفة وهو يطوف حول الكعبة.
يقول في مقدمة كتابه "ذخائر الأعلاق"،
وهو كتاب يشرح فيه ديوانه "ترجمان الأشواق"؛
إنه كان يطوف ذات ليلة بالبيت الحرام،
فتذكَّر أبياتاً من الشعر وأنشدها بهدوء،
بحيث لا يُسمِع إلا نفسه، ومن يليه لو كان هناك أحد.
تقول
الأبيات:
لَيْتَ شِعْرِي هَلْ دَرَوْ... أَيَّ قَلْبٍ مَلَكُو
وَفُؤَادِي لَوْ دَرَى...أَيَّ شِعْبٍ سَلَكُو
هَلْ تُرَاهُمْ سَلِمُو... أَمْ تُرَاهُمْ هَلَكُو
حَارَ أَرْبَابُ الْهَوَى...فِي الْهَوَى وَارْتَبَكُو
ثم يتابع فيقول:
فلم أشعر إلا بضربة بين كتفيَّ بكفّ ألين من الخزّ،
فإذا بجارية من بنات الروم،
لم أرَ أحسنَ منها وجهاً،
ولا أعذبَ منطِقاً،
ولا أرقَّ حاشيةً،
ولا ألطفَ معنىً،
ولا أدقَّ إشارةً،
ولا أظرفَ محاوَرةً،
قد فاقت أهل زمانها ظُرفاً وأدباً وجمالاً ومعرفةً.
طلبت هذه الفتاة من ابن عربي أن يُعيد ما قاله،
وأخذت تستوقفه وتناقشه في الأبيات بيتاً بيتاً...
فسألها ابن عربي :
يا بنت الخالة، ما اسمك؟
قالت: قرّة العين.
فقال: لي...
جواب ابن عربي (لي)،
كان بمثابة رسالة مودّة إلى الفتاة.
لكن قرّة العين أو النظام سلّمت وانصرفت، دون أن تردّ،
تاركة قلب ابن عربي يحترق بنار الحب.
يقول ابن العربي في الباب الثالث والستين وأربعمائة،
من كتابه  الفتوحات المكية؛
إنه كان من أكره خلق الله تعالى في النساء وفي الجِماع
في أول دخوله إلى التصوُّف،
وكان عمره حوالي العشرين سنة.
وبقي على ذلك نحواً من "ثمان عشرة سنة"،
أي أن لقاءه بالنظام كان لحظة فارقة في حياته،
النظام ستصالحه مع المرأة الحبيبة،
وسوف تكون محددة في تأنيث نظرته للوجود.
يقول ابن عربي في وصف النظام:
"بنت عذراء،
طفلةٌ هيفاءُ،
تُقيِّد النظر وتُزيِّن المَحاضِر،
وتُسرّ المُحاضر،
وتُحيّر المناظر،
تُسمى بالنظام،
وتُلقب بعين الشمس والبهاء،
من العالمات العابدات،
السائحات الزاهدات،
شيخة الحرمين،
وتربية البلد الأمين،
الأعظم بلا مَين.
ساحرةُ الطرفِ،
عراقيَّة الظُرف،
إن أسهبت أتعبت،
وإن أوجزت أعجزت،
وإن أفصحت أوضحت.
إن نطقت خَرِسَ قسُّ بنُ ساعدةَ،
وإن كَرُمت خَنَسَ مَعنُ بنُ زائدة،
وإن وفَّت قصَّر السموءل خُطاه،
وأغرى ورأى بظهر الغَرر وامتطاه.
ولولا النفوس الضعيفة سريعة الأمراض سيئة الأغراض،
لأخذتُ في شرح ما أودع الله تعالى في خَلقها من الحُسن،
وفي خُلُقِها الذي هو روضةُ المُزْنِ،
شمسٌ بين العلماء،
بستان بين الأدباء،
حُقَّةٌ مختومة، واسطة عِقدٍ منظومة،
يتيمة دهرها،
كريمة عصرها.
مسكنُها جيادٌ وبيتها من العينِ السوادُ ومن الصدر الفؤاد،
أشرقت بها تهامه،
وفتح الروض لمجاورتها أكمامه.
عليها مسحة مَلَكٍ وهمَّة مَلِك."
اختلفت الآراء حول طبيعة علاقة ابن عربي والنظام بنت رستم الكيلاني.
بعضهم اعتبر ان الحب الذي جمعهما هو حب عذري أفلاطوني،
وإن الصور الحسية في ديوان ترجمان الأشواق هي إحالة لصور رمزية،
في حين ذهب البعض الآخر إلى القول،
بأن ابن عربي بالفعل ارتبط بالنظام وعاشا قصة حب حقيقية،
انتهت بالفراق لأسباب مجهولة.
ربّما ما يرجّح الفرضية الثانية،
هو ما ذكره ابن عربي نفسه حيث يقول:
"إنه عرفها وعاشرها ورأى عندها من لطائف المعارف ما لا يصفه واصف."
ويقول كذلك:
إذا ما التقينا للوداع حسبتنا
لدى الضم والتعنيق حرفًا مشدّدا
فنحن وإن كنا مثنى شخوصنا
فما تنظر الأبصار إلا موحَّدا...
من خصائص الكتابة الصوفية عند ابن عربي في ديوانه ترجمان الأشواق ؛
الإستعارة،
فأغلب رموزه مستعارة من المعجم العاطفي الغزلي الذي يتداوله الشعراء.
هذا المعجم سيثير حفيظة الفقهاء وعامة الناس،
لأنهم لم يدركوا ان المعاني عند ابن عربي لا تكشف عن هويتها مباشرة،
بل تحتجب خلف أستار الصورة المجازية.
وراء الصورة السطحية للغزل العذري المباشر في ترجمان الأشواق،
توجد دلالة روحانية تنبع من أعماق تجربة عرفانية قوية.
الغزل الروحاني داخل ديوان ترجمان الأشواق،
سيأخذنا إلى صورة الأنثى ومكانة المرأة في فكر محيي الدين بن عربي.
وبالمناسبة أحيلكم على كتاب هام جدا،
من بين المراجع التي اعتمدتها في هذا البحث
للكاتبة المغربية نزهة براضة،
يحمل عنوان "الأنوثة في فكر ابن عربي ".
وكذلك احيلكم على دراسة هامة جدا للدكتور المِصري حامد طاهر،
حملت عنوان؛ "مكانة المرأة عند ابن عربي".
تتجلّى المرأة في أثر ابن عربي في عدة صور،
صورة المرأة الحبيبة،
والتي تجلّت في النظام بنت رستم الكيلاني،
وصورة المرأة الأم والتي تجلّت في والدته نور،
ولها مكانة خاصة عند ابن عربي،
لأنها شجعته على المضي في طريق التصوف، عكس والده الذي عارضه.
وصورة المرأة الزوجة وهي مريم بنت محمد بن عبدون،
وذكر ابن عربي أنها من العابدات السالكات لطريق التصوف،
وأنها وصلت لمقام المشاهدة.
وقد أنجبت له ولدين وبنتا.
وصورة المرأة الشيخةً المربية،
وابن عربي من أكثر الصوفية اعترافاً بمكانة المتصوفات
اللاتي تتلمذ على أيديهنّ.
ومن أهم شيخاته :
فاطمة بنت ابن المثنى القرطبي،
التي تحدثنا عنها في الحلقة الفارطة،
والتي اعتبرها أمه الإلهية،
مقابل نور أمه الترابية.
أما شيخته ومربيته الثانية، فهى شمس، التي لقبها بأم الفقراء،
ويتحدث عنها فيقول:
"لم أر أحداً من الرجال كان يقدر على ما تقدر عليه من العبادة،
وهي من أكابر المجتهدات،
كانت حاكمة على وهمها،
كثيرة الوصال في الصوم، على كبر سنها".
أمّا شيخته الثالثة فهي جارية قسيم الدولة، أمير حلب،
التي التقاها في مكّة
و يذكر أنها كانت على قدر كبير من الزهد والعبادة،
حتى أنها قد أوتيت كرامة مخاطبة الجبال والأحجار والأشجار.
ويذكر ابن عربي أيضاً،  شيخته زينب القلعية، من قلعة بنى حماد،
والتي تتلمذ على يديها في الأندلس والحجاز.
ابن عربي سوف يرسّخ تقليدا صوفيا
يقرّ بأهلية المرأة للعرفان والقرب الإلهي،
ومشروعية تعلّم الرجل عنها في مجالسها.
فالحسن البصري قبله كان يقول لصحبه:
هيّا بنا إلى  المُؤَدِّبة متحدّثا عن رابعة العدوية.
والصوفي الشهير ذي النون المصري
تعلّم على يدي الشيخة فاطمة النيسابورية.
صورة المرأة في الفكر الأكبري،
أي فكر الشيخ الأكبر محيي الدين بن عربي،
تدور حول حديثين نبويين رئيسيين:
الأوّل هوّ الحديث القائل؛
"حُبِّبَ إليّ من دنياكم ثلاث:
النّساء والطيب، وجُعلت قرّة عيني في الصلاة".
سيخصص ابن عربي الفصّ الأخير من كتابه  "فصوص الحكم"،
والذي عنونه بـ"فصّ حكمةٍ فرديّة في كلمة محمّدية" لشرح هذا الحديث.
و يلاحظ أن تقديم النساء في الحديث على الطيب والصلاة
دليلًا على المقام الكبير للأنثى.
و يضيف أن الرسول قال في حديثه:
حُبب إلي وليس أحببت،
أي أن محبة النساء لم تكن من تلقاء نفسه وإنما كانت محبة بأمر إلهي.
أمّا الحديث النبوي الثاني الذي يعتمده ابن عربي،
ليبرهن على تكامل وتساوي المرأة والرجل، هو الحديث القائل:
"النساء شقائق الرجال"،
أي نظائرُهم وأمثالهم،
ولكن ذللك لا يلغي ان للمرأة وللرجل كيانين منفصلين،
وانطلاقا من هذه المسلمة،
يؤسس ابن عربي تصوره للإنسان ككيان انقسم إلى نصفين،
وظهر منه الرجل والمرأة.
يرى ابن عربي أنّ عين ذات المرأة متأخرّة في الظهور عن عين ذات الرّجل.
عندما استوحش آدم في الجنة،
خلق اللّه له حواء وأوجدها منه، فهي قطعة منه،
لذلك فحنين الرجل  إلى المرأة هو حنين الكل إلى جزئه المكمل لوجوده،
وحنين المرأة للرجل هو حنين الغريب المفارق لوطنه.
ابن عربي سوف يقدّم قراءة اخرى للأسطورة
التي نجدها في الثقاقة اليهودية و المسيحية والإسلامية على حد السواء
والقائلة ان المرأة خُلقت من ضلع اعوج لآدم،
وهي مصدر النظرة الإستعلائية للرجل تجاه المرأة،
ابن عربي سوف يجعل من هذا الإعوجاج عين  الإستقامة فيقول:
"حواء خلقت من القصير فقَصُرت،
وعَوَجُها استقامتها.
فانحناؤها حنوّها على أبنائها وعلى ما له من الخزائن،
مثل انحناء الأضلاع على ما في الجوف من الأحشاء
والأمعاء المختزنة فيه لصلاح صاحبه.
فاعوجاجُها عين استقامتها التي أريدت له،
ولهذا اعوجاج القوس عين استقامته،
فإن رمت أن تقيمه على الذى تأمله،
وهذا لجهلك بالاستقامة اللائقة به."
يعتبر ابن عربي،
أن الأنثى هي تجلّ للوصل بين الإلهي والبشري،
لأنها ذات رحم،
والرحم هو شجنة من الاسم الإلهي الرحمن الذي هو صيغة مبالغة للرحمة،
وكما جاء في الحديث النبوي :
"الرحم شجنة من الرحمن، من وصلها وصله الله، ومن قطعها قطعه الله"،
حسب ابن عربي رحمة الأم تجاه أطفالها هي قبس من رحمة الاهية مطلقة.
ويذهب ابن عربي ابعد من ذلك في رفع مكانة الأنثى،
عندما يعتبرها أصل الوجود، فيقول:
إنَّا إنَاثٌ لما فِينَا يُولِّد اللّه...
مَا فِي الكونِ من رَجل...
إنَّ الرجَالَ الذِين العرفُ عَيَّنهم...
هم الانَاثُ وَهم سُؤلِي وَهم أملي...
لماذا يجعل ابن عربي الأنثى أصل الوجود؟
لأن الوجود في تقدير ابن عربي يقوم على مبدئين أساسيين وهما:
الخلق والتكاثر؛
في عملية الخلق  المرأة هي المكمل الوجودي للرجل،
و في عملية التكاثر المرأة هي المنفعل الوجودي للرجل.
عند ابن عربي المرأة من الرجل هي بمنزلة الطبيعة من الأمر الإلهى.
لأن المرأة محل وجود الأبناء،
كما أن الطبيعة للأمر الإلهى هي محل ظهور أعيان الأجسام.
فيها تكونت وعنها ظهرت.
فأمر بلا طبيعة لا يكون، وطبيعة بلا أمر لا تكون .
فالكون متوقف على الأمرين.
فمن عرف مرتبة الطبيعة عرف مرتبة المرأة.
ومن عرف الأمر الإلهى فقد عرف مرتبة الرجل.
وأن الموجودات – مما سوى الله – متوقف وجودها على هاتين الحقيقتين.
والنتيجة أن المرأة بدون الرجل لا شىء،
كما أن الرجل بدون المرأة .. لا شىء !
يشبّه ابن عربي في الفتوحات المكيّة المرأة بالزهرة فيقول:
"ولما كانت الزهرة دليلة على الثمرة ،
ومُتنزّها للبصر،
ومُعطية الرائحة الطيّبة،
فإن صاحب الزهرة ( أي الزوج) إذا لم يدرك رائحتها،
ولا شَهِدها زهرة وإنما شَهِدها امرأة ،
ولا عَلِم دلالتها التى سبقت له على الخصوص،
وزُوجت به،
وتنعّم بها،
ونال منها ما نال بحَيَوانِيته لا بروحه وعقله،
فلا فرق بينه وبين سائر الحيوان، بل الحيوان خير منه".
يعتبر ابن عربي ان اللقاء الحميمي بين الرجل والمرأة
ليس لمجرّد حفظ النسل البشري بل له معنى إلاهي،
وفي غياب هذا المعنى تصبح ممارسة الحب مجرّد "صورة بلا روح."
يذهب ابن عربى إلى أن إطلاق كل من (الذات) و(الصفة) على الله،
وكلاهما لفظ تأنيث هو شرف للتأنيث:
وذلك جبرا لقلب المرأة الذى يكسره من لا علم له بالأمر من الرجال!
ويقول كذلك ان المكان الذي لا يؤنث لا يعوّل عليه،
لأن التأنيث يضيف تاء التأنيث للمكان فيتحوّل من مكان إلى مكانة.
الباحث في الفكر الأكبري،
تعترضه أحيانا أفكار مدهشة مثل قول الشيخ الأكبر محيي الدين بن عربي هذا:
إن النساء شقائق الذكران
في عالم الأرواح والأبدان
والحُكم متحد الوجود عليهما
وهو المعبّر عنه بالإنسان
وتفرّقنا عنه بأمر عارض
فُصل الإناث به من الذكران
من رتبة الإجماع يحكم فيهما
بحقيقة التوحيد في الأعيان.
أي ان صفتي الذكر والأنثى عند ابن عربي
هما صفتان عارضتان للكينونة الأصل وهي الإنسان.
بعد حوالي 800 عام،
سنجد صدى هذه الفكرة في كتاب "الجنس الآخر" للمفكّرة النسوية الفرنسية سيمون دي بوفوار،
عندما قالت: لا تُولد المرأة امرأة.. وإنّما تُصبح كذلك!
اتوقّف عند هذا الحد لأعود إليكم في الحلقة القادمة،
لأتحدّث عن كتاب الفتوحات المكية،
أهم مؤلفات الشيخ الأكبر محيي الدين بن عربي.
هذا نجيب البكوشي من باريس،
أشكركم جزيل الشكر على المتابعة،
دمتم بخير،
وإلى لقاء قريب على قناة أنا أفكر إذن أنا موجود...